Na wunderbar, ok ich hoffe jetzt gehts wieder, also ich hab Vodafone auch schonmal angeschrieben,
also falls wirklich irgendwelche krassen DDoSer Dudes am Start sind, gibts jetzt IP Wechsel,
ich bin halt immer doof, dass das nötig ist, aber meinetwegen, kurz reloaden, es könnte
auch sein, dass Vodafone selbst Probleme hat, aber es war schon sehr auffällig, wir wissen
ja, hier gibts irgendwie Leute mit Polen, Netz und allem am Start, aber jetzt will was willst du machen?
Also bei mir ist Vodafone komplett repp, ich vermute mal eher, dass wieder irgendwelche
Polen DDoS Leute am Start sind, ich war halt ein bisschen fail, aber normalerweise reißen
sich die Leute zusammen, aber es gibt halt hin und wieder welche, die können sich nicht verkneifen.
Wir haben kurz den Tor Browser aufgemacht und irgendwie erstmal DDoS eingekauft, was auch immer.
Bei mir schreiben die Leute jetzt schon in den Chat, meine Zuschauer gehen jetzt wieder runter,
weil du jetzt wieder da bist. Ich lass beides auf Leute, wir machen das so,
also ich mach jetzt weiter, mal gucken, vielleicht gehts jetzt, ich hab Vodafone aber schon
kontaktiert, die machen jetzt IP Wechsel dann demnächst. Ja ok super. Ich bin jetzt leider
in der Zwischenzeit nicht weitergekommen, ich war oft. Nein, kein Stress, kein Stress. Also wenn du
speedchamp.org aufrufst, kriegst du zumindest schon mal ne Testseite, kannst du nicht viel mit
anfangen, aber ich kümmere mich jetzt um den Zertifikat und dann machen wir den Rest. Ich
sag dir gleich Bescheid, sollte schnell gehen, aber ja, geht nicht so agil wie erhofft. Kann sein,
als ich demnächst wieder weg bin, dann musst du erwarten bis Vodafone das gewechselt hat,
aber sollte halbwegs schnell gehen. Ok, alles klar. Ich sag dir gleich Bescheid bis denn. Alright. Ok,
nice. Also Leute, weiter gehts. Hoffe mal, dass es jetzt funktioniert. Ich mach jetzt mal, ich will
gucken, ob es kaputt geht. Ich lasse es einfach ping laufen, damit er kommt. Also wo wir stehengeblieben
sind, ich wollte ein Zertifikat ausstellen für speedchamp. Das hätten wir eigentlich schon seit
Ewigkeiten fertig haben sollen, aber naja. Mein Payal hat den DNS Eintritt noch nicht. Echt nicht?
Ja, speedchamp.org. Innebar Kabel kriegt man nicht in euer IP, das muss Vodafone machen.
Also unser Lokalaservice läuft auf Port 5000, das wissen wir. Das heißt wir machen jetzt Reverse
Proxy, Port 5000, allerdings müssen wir die Domain eingeben und unsere Domain ist speedchamp.org und
ja, das war's. Ich glaube da muss man das klammern oder so. Ich bin mir bei der Syntax ehrlich
gesagt unsicher, ob das so ging, ob man so Reverse Proxien kann. Mal schauen. Sollen wir mal gucken.
Ich hoffe, das stellt jetzt gleich ein Zertifikat aus und dann kann ich am Backend weiter
programmieren. Sollte eigentlich funktionieren. Okay, System, CTL, Restart, Kadi. Das ist halt echt
blöd. Wir setzen Erwerbung die ganze Zeit. Ich hab's extra kleiner gemacht, nur um in die Ecke
geschoben. Musste es mal ausprobieren, wie das funktioniert. Dein Overlay zeigt noch nicht die
Chat-Nachrichten an. Echt nicht? Ach stimmt. Ich glaube, das ist RIP.
Jetzt sollte es wieder funktionieren. Also falls einer von den Mods da ist,
es wäre cool, wenn ihr Ausrufezeichen heute und den YouTube-Link zum Noel machen könntet.
Okay, also weiter im Text. Hat es jetzt funktioniert mit Zertifikat? Wir haben Zertifikat, Leute.
Bam. Connection secure. Let's Encrypt. Easy. So einfach geht's. Wir haben Zertifikat. Also,
das Ganze ist passend eingerichtet. Wunderbar. Klappt. Mehr müssen wir auf dem Server erst
mal nicht machen. Das passt. So, jetzt kann ich bereits sagen. So, Server ist eingerichtet,
passt. Wenn du Speedchamp.org guckst, haben wir jetzt ein gültiges Zertifikat. Okay, wunderbar.
Können wir loslegen. Speedchamp.org. Ja. Okay, und dann dementsprechend halt klar den Postrequest
mache. Also wir kriegen, da läuft noch nichts, ne? Ich hab noch nichts hingeschrieben. Aber du
solltest ein Zertifikat, ein gültiges bekommen. Ja, das geht. Der Proxied. Echt nicht? Ja,
du bekommst ein 502, das ist richtig. Genau. Du bekommst ein 502, weil der Applikationswappen,
wo er draufschiebt, noch nicht da ist. Aber das gültige Zertifikat kriegst du schon. Okay,
alles klar. Also heißt, ich kann jetzt darauf auschecken und laufen. Wobei da steht,
bei mir diese Webseite besitzt kein Zertifikat. Bei mir sagt er, es ist Connection secure.
Das ist vielleicht ein Caching-Problem. Ich geh mal kurz auf Chrome. Ah, Chrome checkt's nicht.
Alles klar, Firefox funktioniert. Chrome macht nicht weiter, weil es einen 502 gibt. Da muss
ich doch die Anwendung noch drauf starten. Weil dem Firefox sagt er mir schon, es ist ein
Let's Encrypt-Zertifikat. Ah, okay. Also es funktioniert. Dann check ich jetzt einfach mal
die Anwendung da drauf aus und starte die. Und ach so, ich hab gar kein.NET drauf. Ne,
mach ich jetzt nicht. Sobald es so funktioniert, machen wir das dann. Du brauchst definitiv noch
Docker drauf und da dann ne Container-Ride. Das hab ich mir auch schon überlegt, ob wir das über
Docker und Compose machen. Wir müssen es, wir müssen es nicht übertreiben. Passt. Ach so,
geht jetzt eigentlich die, nachdem hier Vorderfall rumgesponnen hat, geht eigentlich der Coach her
noch? Denke, denke das tut noch. Ich glaube, du müsstest eine neue Session aufmachen. Ah, hier
da ist, ne, der ist angeblich, ist er noch offen, aber ich kann dich noch mal einladen. Die Session
ist noch auf, aber die, wahrscheinlich bist du rausgeflogen aus der Session. Ähm, lass mich mal
gucken. Ich bin rausgeflogen, also du müsstest mich noch mal neu einladen. Müsste, müsste sein. Ach
hier, Accept. Danke schön für den Sub, der Kommentator. Ja, passt. Bis zum Startup seh ich.
Alles klar, dann klappt das wieder. Cool. Alright. Alles klar, gut, was machen wir jetzt? Also dann
packe ich jetzt die Anwendung mal kurz auf den Server drauf, dass du auch siehst, dass das alles
funktioniert. Und dann wäre ich bereit, Backend Sachen zu basteln. Yes. Okay. Dann mach ich das
schnell, sag dir gleich nochmal Bescheid. Und dann kannst du, da können wir bei mir im Stream auch
mal schnell dann gleich gucken. Ich mach die Anwendung drauf und da kannst du ja mal committen,
wenn es soweit ist und dann können wir uns die mal anschauen. Genau, machen wir so. Okay, ich sag
ein paar Minuten Bescheid. Alright. Richtig hyperagile jetzt. Jetzt geht's los. Jetzt,
wo Wodafone hoffentlich wieder geht. Alles klar, bis gleich. Yes. So Leute, also was wir jetzt
machen ist folgendes. Schade ein bisschen, dass das jetzt so abgekackt ist. Wir waren mal 400
Zuschauern, aber kannst nicht machen. Ich bin froh, dass ihr alle da seid. Cool, dass ihr zuguckt,
auch wenn es heute ein bisschen Technikkram ist. Haben wir C, CD? Haben wir noch nicht? Wir machen
GitHub Actions gleich. So, ich werde mir den Kram mal kurz klonen. Kommt Ansible? Weiß ich noch
nicht, ob wir da jetzt Ansible für machen. So, ich clone mir mal kurz das GitHub Repo. JIT clone.
Und ich installiere mal.NET Ubuntu. Ich installiere mal.NET auf dem Server drauf. Dann können wir
das einfach ausführen. Nee, nee. 20.4. Update und dann install, wahrscheinlich.NET, genau.
Dankeschön Mods. Exzellent, exzellent. Warum nicht gleich GitOps? Warum nicht gleich Azure?
Warum nicht gleich Azure Functions? Warum nicht Netlify? Warum nicht AWS? Ja,
man kann es alles. Es gibt tausend Wege, wie du was machen kannst.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs. Ich habe es jetzt gerade erst noch gesehen.
Der Kommentator ist noch dabei. Fizz und Xenpy. Hab ich glaube ich schon vorgelesen,
aber auch nochmal an euch. Danke. Massive Subscriptions. Hi IQ. IQ++. Um nicht zu sagen.
Massive Big Brain. Warum nicht Cobol ist die eigentliche Frage? Warum nicht Cobol und ABAP?
Das ist die eigentliche Frage hier. So, jetzt haben wir die Anwendung hier drauf. SpeedChamp,
SpeedChamp, Backend und nun.NET Run. So, und jetzt sollte auch was kommen auf speedchamp.org.
Log loss 5000. Passt. Ja, gut. Der kann jetzt nicht so genau. Was hat er für Schmerzen? Habe
ich irgendwas verkehrt gemacht im Reverseproxy? Page not working. Ah, no webpage. Ja, das ist
klar. Gibt ja auch keine Webseite aktuell. 404. Aber 404 ist. Warum zeigt ein Chrome da nichts an?
Sollte mir Chrome nicht bei einem 404 auch ein Zertifikat anzeigen? Bin ich jetzt irgendwie
Hardcore, Hardcore, verwirrt Champ oder Mkdir, WWW, Index, HTML. Gucken wir mal. Hallo. Der
sollte jetzt zumindest irgendwas anzeigen. Firefox geht. Ja, ja, ich weiß. Firefox geht
lustiger, aber es ist komisch. Ich habe ich habe garantiert irgendwas in der in der Konfig
verkehrt gemacht. Localhost. Localhost Port 5000. Irgendwas. Irgendwas funktioniert da nicht.
Schauen gleich Pepega. Guck mal, ich habe irgendwas. Ich habe bestimmt irgendwas in der
Konfig verkehrt gemacht. Etc, Kaddi, Kaddi. Reverseproxy ist eigentlich richtig. Eigentlich
ist ok. Curl. 7.0.0.0.5.000. Slash, Speed, Champ. Ah, ich weiß euch vergessen, ich liefer ja
gar keine Seiten aus. Ok, das muss ich noch einstellen. Es ist nämlich in.NET standardmäßig
so, der liefert keine Seiten aus, obwohl man es angelegt hat. Man muss ihm sagen, explizit
liefere Server, also liefere statische Seiten aus. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt ein Ordner
anlegen. WWW Route. Das ist so der Default Ordner, wo die ganzen HTML Seiten reinkommen.
Da mache ich jetzt irgendwie eine Index, Index HTML rein. Reicht. Hack W. Mehr muss da nicht
drauf. Und jetzt muss ich noch sagen, App Use File Server. Und erst dann surft er diese
Files in WWW Route. Aldir, Dankeschön. Plants vs. Zombies, exzellent. Ich spogge das Game.
Use File Server muss ich machen, sonst funktioniert das Ganze nicht. Ihr könnt jetzt 12701D dorsen.
So, machen wir mal ein neues Commit. Wir sind ja super hyper agil hier. Git add, Git status,
Git commit minus M. Was haben wir gemacht? Edit Default. Kann ich mal schreiben. Edit
Default Page. Ne, wir machen es anders. Enabled Pile Serving. Ist ASP.NET outdated? Das ist
ja auch nicht ASP.NET, das ist ASP.NET Core. ASP.NET Core ist das neue und super aktuell
und es kam quasi erst vor ein paar Tagen auf der Microsoft Build eine neue Preview Version
raus. Agile Champs sind am Champen, so sieht es aus. Ich lösche den Kram noch mal kurz
und check das nochmal neu aus. Ah, Wodafone hat sich gemeldet. Exzellent. Wodafone war
meine Kundennummer. Wodafone braucht meine Kundennummer. Moment.
Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer. Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer. Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer.
Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer. Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer. Wodafone ist meine
Kundennummer. Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer. Wodafone ist meine Kundennummer. Wodafone
waren wir genau ich habe kommited ich habe kommited und wollte das ganze noch mal kurz
klonen klonen speed speed champ klont jetzt sollte zumindest die standard seite eigentlich
ausliefern speed champ speed champ back end dotnet run so und wenn jetzt klappt jeezypro
dankeschön für den sub und jetzt sollte er eigentlich die seite ausliefern standardmäßig
steht dann in der seite glaube ich keck keck weh oder so läuft und und und keck weh bäm da
sind wir leute und gültiges zertifikat ok ok bin ready seite geht wenn der refresh zertifikat
ist da und ab jetzt können wir können wir den kram direkt auf den server pushen er schreibt
es geht noch alles ja ich habe ich habe gerade vergessen ich habe schon gedacht
wunderbar in welches ich würde da mal mein projekt bauen in welches in welchen ordner
von dir soll ich das dann mal rein das zeige ich dir mach mal kurz visual studio code please auf
mit dem mit dem gescherten code also ich habe jetzt du musst dann auch noch mal pullen vorher ich
habe jetzt noch eingestellt dass der statische files ausliefert hier use files das musst du
noch machen ansonsten jetzt überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat mich schon ich habe mich schon
die ganze zeit gewundert warum gibt es keine seiten wenn du das aufmachst aber klar wenn
er keine statischen seiten ausliefert kann es auch keine seiten geben genau also muss das hier
reinschieben guck mal es gibt da einen ww root da gibt es eine index html drin die habe ich nur
zum testen reingemacht die kannst du überbügeln all right alles klar genau dann mache ich das
genau kann es vorher noch mal muss muss vorher noch einmal einmal pullen oder ganz bescheid sagen dann
soll ich irgendwas backern technische schon machen an sich an sich gerne ja ja nur die frage was
wie machen wir also also meine ich muss jetzt mir erst mal überlegen wie ich quasi berechne wie
viele mbit das sind on the fly sozusagen während dem upload prozess ja big brain time sozusagen
ganz ganz big brain time ich stehe halt wirklich total auf dem schlaufe müsste es echt mal
gucken ich weiß nicht was du machen könntest ich könnte ich könnte zumindest also wenn du
wenn du jetzt du upload ist ja dann einfach mal wir haben uns ja im vorfeld schon mal auf
erst mal auf 20 mb geeinigt haben wir gesagt 20 mb ist eine gute gute größe ich könnte
es so machen ich könnte im back end jetzt einfach mal von dir 20 mb einlesen genau also das wäre
gut wenn du bei dem endpunkt einfach mal das vorbereiten könntest dass ich da quasi wirklich
daten du kannst einfach so viel uploaden wie du willst bei 20 mb hat er dann auch also ich
habe es jetzt so gemacht wir können das gerne so machen ich habe noch so eingebaut dass der
nutzer sich noch selektieren kann aber wir können es ja trotzdem erst noch 20 mb limitieren genau
wir machen erst mal 20 mb ja genau wir waren erst mal erst mal 20 mb hard code und dann gucken
wir das baue ich jetzt ein und kannst du kommenten und pushen kannst mir dann einfach bescheid sagen
dann pull ich das mal und dann mache ich ein update mal auf dem server da können wir es
sonst dann angucken ok jetzt alles klar dann mute ich mich wieder so chat big brain time ich gucke
mal kurz beim null in den stream rein wie es da ausschaut was da was da abgeht gerade gucken wir
ach ne jetzt sind wir grad bei mir im controller ok vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht auch mal
die quali ein bisschen höher machen speedchamp 20 mb leute 20 mb reicht 20 mb also von der idee
her funktioniert es ja folgendermaßen wenn also wenn ich jetzt das im backend testen würde
würde ich das folgendermaßen machen also ich schreibe das jetzt einfach mal als kommentar auf
20 mb upload machen wir machen wir es doch schon mal so war upload sei es gleich 20 wie viel sind
20 mb in bytes 20 20 20 millionen kann das sein huge huge brain chat kommt hin oder ok
ja das zwei und sieben nuller ok passt also dass das müssten zwanz das müssten 20 mb sein wenn
das wenn das halbwegs halbwegs stimmt was ich da low i cute habe
also dann machen wir das jetzt folgendermaßen nachdem ich nicht genau weiß was er neu genau
im frontend macht mache ich jetzt einfach mal so ich lese sinnlos einfach ein der kann so viel
upload ne das mache ich nicht das mache ich nicht der kann nicht so viel uploaden wie er will weil
wenn ich das auf den server schiebe dann weiß ich genau dann starten die ersten leute einfach
nur endlich lang download nur endlich lang upload und machen den server voll und ich habe eine
hetzer server rechnung von 5000 euro ich kann es mir schon richtig vorstellen nein nein nein das
würde der chat natürlich niemals machen sowas nie würdet ihr das machen ich wie komme ich
wie komme ich drauf dass sie sowas machen würdet na ok also sagen wir mal upload sei es sind 20 mb
20 mb schreibe auch mal dahin megabytes heute ist es ja mehr deutsch mit mibi und mobi und was
es da nicht alles gibt so und dann brauchen wir den buffer wo man den ganzen kram reinschreiben
buffer gleich new byte array in upload sei es so weit von der theorie her ich weiß jetzt noch
nicht genau wie es weitergeht ok so und dann von der theorie her funktioniert es folgendermaßen
zeit stoppen also im prinzip zeit zeit wie nennen wir das also stopp ur starten upload einlesen wenn
upload größer größer gleich 20 mb zeit stoppen und dann quasi upload sei es durch zeit so weit
müsste das das müsste ungefähr die upload geschwindigkeit geben also ich lese 20 mb ein
und startet die stoppe die zeit wie lange es dauert 20 mb einzulesen 20 mb ist halt das problem dass
20 mb ja nach nach geschwindigkeit wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ungenau sein könnte also ja
ich dachte er kommt erst in die upload methode rein wenn der body fertig empfangen wurde
ne wir machen jetzt wir machen jetzt war alles gepusht was alles gepusht ich habe ich habe
gepusht kann es mal gucken ob es irgendwie funktioniert ich pull mark kurz geht pull origin
master ok der request wird wahrscheinlich noch nicht funktionieren weil ich da hardcoded local
host drin stehen habe ich aber wenn die seite aus dir liefert wird dann ist das schon mal die
habe ich bin ja noch dabei am am einlesen von von einem upload habe ich noch nicht noch nicht
fertig soll ich mal soll ich auf dem server gucken schon mal bei mir im stream zeigen wie
die seite jetzt ausschaut oder was erst mal lokal lassen ich meine ich meine an sich ist
jetzt noch nicht so viel ganz gerne zeigen aber da gucken wir gucken uns das mal kurz an ich
hoffe muss nur gucken dass ich keinen sinntagsfehler produziert habe sonst funktioniert das ganze
nämlich nicht so gepullt habe ich schon das vorher mal updaten nicht dass das ich habe
meinem chat noch vor gesagt wir müssen uns da noch ein gutes emote raussuchen was wir dann
das titel nutzen ja gleich sehen ist ganz wichtig dass also wir brauchen wir brauchen sowohl das
und wir brauchen unbedingt so den so einen faf eiken yes also ohne ohne ohne geht es
geht es ja nicht das stimmt ich push jetzt meinen kam auch mal kurz dann gehe ich auf
den server drauf und hol mal das aktuelle so wunderbar das ist jetzt zwar sehr unagil
muss ich mal sagen ja wir pushen das und ich pulse dann auf dem server von hand da müsste
jetzt ja eigentlich die continuous integration pipeline anlaufen damit das richtig richtig
wäre wir machen nachher github actions draus so da ist es leute sieht das nicht geil aus
guckt euch mal knopf upload größe wählen und hier unten hast du hardcoded werte reingeschrieben
genau das ist der chet versagt macht doch schon mal macht doch schon mal macht doch schon was
herr ich guck mal kurz in den source code rein was du für ob es ist von hand ge- hallo elements
hast du es von hand gemacht das css oder hast du irgendein css framework drin? ich hab ich hab ich
hab tailwind tailwind hab ich schon mega geil tailwind ist nice ja tailwind ist richtig geil
monero ja wie cristiano ronaldo ne wobei was war denn monero? ich glaube es war monero oder
oder ethereum oder so ich weiß es nicht genau zumindest hat christiano ronaldo auf seiner
website ja auch coins coins gemeint wobei ich davon ausgehe der hat der typ der typ
weiß das ja nicht das hat irgendeinen admin gemacht ich glaube christiano ronaldo ist
keiner der zur damaligen zeit irgendwie einen plan davon hatte was kryptowährung ist das ist
ja schon zwei jahre her jetzt schon jetzt sind sie alle dabei aber cool passt ja wenn ich jetzt
hier auf upload drücke dann geht wahrscheinlich nix genau genau ne genau dann sagt er hier geht
nicht wunderbar ja dann baue ich das mal ein dann ist der ich ich lese einfach 20 mb ein und nach
20 mb höre ich auf okay oder ich gucke einfach ob es größer weil ich ich darf nicht mehr einlesen
weil ich weiß genau sonst gibt es der erste im chat der ist schon am start mit seinem upload
server und pumpt das ding voll wer wusste man muss ja hier an alles denken ja call up nächste
nächste stream how to implement dedos sagst nicht so laut nächste stream machen wir folgendes ich
hab es mir schon überlegt wenn das hier funktioniert machen wir das frontend auf netlify
und mein backend kommt dann azure funtions und dann sind wir richtig agil dann sind wir dabei
dann haben wir die 30.000 euro rechnung ich habe noch ich habe noch von der schulung ich
habe noch 200 euro gutschein das machen wir dann man kann ich glaube man kann den nicht
überziehen weil auf den schulungs accounts musst du keine zahlungs sachen hinterlegen
das smart also im prinzip ist das geht es dann wahrscheinlich einfach aus oder so das ist das
ist klug das ist echt klug ich brauche schnell ein mit dass der 20 mb einliest und du kannst ja
gucken dass du nicht auf localhost gehst jetzt genau habe ich schon implementiert und da gucken
wir mal zusammen gleich wieder also leute weiter 20 mb upload hardcode jetzt erst mal ihr habt
ja gesehen im frontend man kann das dann später auswählen aber ok ohne scrum poker seid ihr echt
nicht sehr agil ja wie gesagt die tribe meetings fehlen auch und eitel sind wir eitel zertifiziert
ich muss nur nur mal fragen nur sag mal bist du eitel zertifiziert ich auch nicht kann das mit
der qualität doch gar nichts werden bis wenigstens vielleicht den iso 9001 oder safe oder irgendwas
gar nicht ich auch nicht qualitäts management ist bei mir unten durch aber ich auch nicht
danach fangen wir an wir brauchen den chat der chat ist unsere qualitätssicherung ich bin
qualität ist egal der speed champ ist 27 001 zertifiziert ganz klar der ist hochsecure das
hat man heute schon gesehen zweimal den auswählen ich mache jetzt weiter ich gucke mal ich gucke
mal schnell ich gucke mal schnell noch mal hier in chat ob ich irgendwas beantworten kann falls
es fragen zu dort nett oder so gab ich glaube aber nicht ich glaube nicht bei max stehen 20
millionen bei als 20 mb ihr kommt da ungefähr hin das sind da wobei da kommt ungefähr hin sind
das sind das megabyte es gibt auch mehbi und mega und so da blick ich nicht mehr durch das genau die
genau die unterhaltung hatte ich mit meinem mit meinem chat vorher auch ich glaube mega ist
jetzt neuerdings komplett 1000 und mehbi ist 1024 es kann aber auch genau umgedreht sein wie ihr
sagt ich weiß ich gebe das ich gebe das offenbar ehrlich zu ich habe keine ahnung bei dir ist aber
noch nicht so lange her bei mir gab es das alles noch gar nicht bei mir gab es das alles noch
gar nicht ich kann mich auch genau dran erinnern mit meinem berufsschullehrer mir das erklärt hat
und ich hoffe dass er mir nachher nicht schreibt und mir sagt na guck mal warum hast du eigentlich
damals nicht aufgepasst ich würde sagen wir machen es ganz einfach wir sind wir machen wir
sagen einfach 20 millionen bytes dann immer das gleiche einfach 20 und 60 dass das front end
soll der kunde sich selber irgendwie zugänglich machen gibt es gibt es auch schon seit jahren gibt
es auch schon seit jahren dass leute die sagen demnächst braucht man keine programmierer mehr
weil man das alles zusammen klicken kann ich warte noch drauf ja bis jetzt ist noch nicht
eingetreten nee das stimmt ich soll dich übrigens fragen warum du auf youtube streamst weil ich
twitch gar nicht eingerichtet habe aber und halt auch keinen gescheiten twitch account habe ich
habe noch einen ganz alten account von let's play zeiten aber bei dir gucken die leute einfach
auch über youtube weil du auf youtube die abos hast wer ja blöd jetzt auf twitch zu streamen wo
keiner mitbekommt also an sich wäre es vielleicht klug parallel zu streamen oder so weil twitch ist
eindeutig die bessere plattform haben wir vorher gemerkt was allein einstellung und so weiter
angeht aber youtube einfach weil da der die community ist ja würde ich auch so machen also
wenn ich auf youtube die zuschauer hätte klar leuchtet ein so chat zufrieden alles klar ok ich
baue eins ich lese einfach 20 mb ein dann höre ich auf und dann können wir gucken ob das funktioniert
alles da sagt ihr bescheid perfekt hier huge huge pair programming wir pair program übrigens
gar nicht fällt mir ein aber wir aber wir sind wir sind agil wir sind wir sind hyper angel kadel
also ok war weiter upload size 20 mb ok das heißt theoretisch muss ich jetzt folgendes machen ich
hätte fast einen speedtest aufgemacht lull war keine gute idee gewesen wieder ok also jetzt
machen wir folgendes lass mal kurz lass mal kurz überlegen also wir müssen jetzt einfach upload
einlesen das geht folgendermaßen unter dort nett wusste ich selber nicht wie man das unter
sp.net core macht ehrlich gesagt da habe ich stack overflow befragt weil ihr wisst ja wenn
man keine ahnung hat fragt man einfach stack overflow und da habe ich habe ich glaube ich
gesucht nach read raw bytes sp.net core und da habe ich was gefunden wie das funktioniert
das da war es glaube ich genau und dann bin ich drauf gekommen dass das funktio otze ja
oddie read ok ich glaube ich habe mir sie irgendwie dann reversed raus zusammengepasst also das geht
folgendermaßen normalerweise ist es ja so gedacht dass man einen controller hat dieser controller
bekommt hier parameter eine id und ein alter oder was auch immer und im hintergrund kümmert sich das
web framework schon soweit es geht darum dass es aus der url die parameter passt dass es aus
einem jason body die sachen ausliest also das versucht eigentlich schon relativ viel für dich
zu machen deswegen sagen wir jetzt einfach wir machen das gar nicht sondern wir lesen den body
einfach so ein und das geht folgendermaßen das habe ich im vorfeld rausgesucht leute ich habe
ich habe gecheatet die das know he lacks critical information das habe ich im vorfeld rausgesucht
weil ich wusste genau dass ich das brauche dass ich das brauche zwar das geht folgendermaßen
weil und also also so kann man die sache auslesen request body body read async und das macht
folgendes das liest so viele bites allen wie es einlesen kann oder maximal so viele wie in
den buffer passen und gibt als zahl zurück wie viele bites es eingelesen hat also sprich
gebe ich jetzt hier den buffer an und das packe ich in eine schleife rein also sagen wir sowas
hier was der fuck nein nein nein hier ist sofort das packe ich in eine schleife rein wir brauchen
auch eine variabler wo wir die länge das aktuellen request reinschreiben und dann sagen wir so was
wie muss man glaube ich noch mal klammern länge gleich das da also sprich wie viel ich aktuell
eingelesen habe und dann größer so größer null das heißt dem was habe ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht
ja ich bin dumm habe es eine klammer zu weit also was das jetzt macht ist das liest ein so viele
bites aus dem request wie es einlesen kann und merkt sich wie viele bites das waren wenn es mehr
als null sind macht er weiter das heißt sobald ich null einlese bedeutet das ich habe alles
eingelesen weil es kommt ja nicht mehr und jetzt muss ich noch irgendwie hochzählen also sprich
quasi was wie count jetzt vielleicht nicht die besten variablen namen count plus gleich
länge also der liest ein und zählt es hoch und jetzt könnte ich noch sowas sagen wie
und keine ahnung und count kleiner upload sei es oder sowas aber scheiß mal drauf lasst
mal weg ich lasse mich ich lasse mich zu spammen zumal das eh nicht schlimm ist die maximale
upload sei es von asp dort net core se glaube 30 mb warum die loop weil es nicht garantiert ist
dass der 20 mb einliest der liest so viel ein wie er für notwendig halten hält also der liest mal
512 ein der liest mal 1024 ein mal 4096 wie es ihm danach ist also er kann maximal 20 mb einlesen
ja aber er wird wahrscheinlich nicht so viel einlesen sondern immer in häppchen allein schon wenn
man sich überlegt so eine tcp paket passen ja nur irgendwie 1,5 kb oder so ungefähr rein
so dann machen wir das dann zählen wir jetzt und jetzt kommt der eigentliche speed test wir brauchen
eine stopwatch also ne was heißt es auf deutsch stopwatch schalt uhr dings stopp uhr stopp uhr
btf was heißt das auf deutsch alter wortwörtlich übersetzt aber stopp uhr es gibt bestimmt bessere
timer klassen dafür aber die ist gar nicht mal so schlecht low IQ ja ich brauche mehr subs leute
seht ihr mal wie weit schon gekommen ist also zu wenig prime subs was das was das eigentlich für
messen auswirkung hat auf den IQ zustand aber nicht nur von mir beim chat ist es ja auch so ihr
merkt es vielleicht noch nicht aber bei euch ist es auch schon weniger geworden hätte noch
dankeschön tritts primes ab huge danke schön für den sub echt moment stopwatch start new gibt so was
messen alle der chat ist wieder massive brain man sieht es bei manchen ist es die bei manchen
ist das hier noch da jan wagg dankeschön für den sub prime subscription ist die stopwatch
monotonik ich bin mir nicht mal ganz sicher was monotonik ist ist das glaube ich ist das
ist das nicht irgendwie sowas dass die immer im gleichen intervall in eine richtung nur zählt
ich habe keine ahnung oder ist es oder ist es eine marke und das war ein witz
du hast sechs monat im voraus gesappt ja gut dann hast du auch mindestens sechs monaten noch
feifert auch ohne sowas wie schaltsekunde was weiß ich nee nee das ist ohne schaltsekunde klar
das ist ohne so dinger das basiert auf cpu tix unten drunter irgendwo also da ist wahrscheinlich
mit schaltsekunden nix so als aber die zeit gemessen und jetzt kann ich jetzt kann ich die
zeit jetzt kann ich die zeit mal ausgeben würde ich sagen also von der idee ist es jetzt ja
folgendermaßen wir haben jetzt ich habe die zeit gestoppt wie lange es dauert 20 mb einzulesse
das ist quasi das hier ist quasi der upload speed test speed test nicht dass er noch probleme
kriegen das ist der upload ich lade so viel ich ich ich lese so viel ein wie geht return
und jason mit bald count und time in sekunden ich würde sagen wir geben jetzt ja gut doch wir
können jason zurückgeben wir können jason zurückgeben wir können jason zurück zurückgeben
mit der zeit ja das können wir jetzt an der stelle tatsächlich machen also return new was
gehen wir da zurück einfach jetzt einfach nur mal nur mal zum zum testen upload gleich aber
wenn wir müssen erst noch mal ausrechnen wir müssen erst noch mal ausrecht was hat man weiter
hier schon wieder gemacht vier spaces was ist da los was der fack zwei spaces bitteschön kommt
er hier an mit vier spaces ich glaube ich glaube ich glaube es geht los dazu kann ich nur sagen
also das war mal nicht vier facheinrückungen hier spaces größer zwei spaces das ist richtig
weil 4 größer 2 aber von der usability her finde ich 2 spaces größer 4 spaces ok also
jetzt können wir hier upload zurückgehen wir müssen das jetzt noch ausrechnen und ich
zeige euch jetzt mal eine richtig coole c sharp library oder finde ich zumindest ganz nice wenn
man nämlich so 3 hat ist wie ich und ich weiß wie man gescheit beides von maybe zu nicht maybe
und und sonstige dinge umrechnen gibt es eine ganz coole library die heißt glaube ich github
ich glaube beid sei es mein tap ist auf zwei spaces gestellt ja guck zwei spaces tap beid
sei es nicht beid sei es beid sei es und da kannst du solche sachen machen wie zum beispiel
beid sei es von megabytes oder von maybe beid es und dann kannst du es umwandeln in andere
sachen das ist für alle das ist für alle low iq leute wie mich man kann das natürlich ohne
probleme selbst machen aber warum selbst machen wenn es da schon was gibt was wahrscheinlich
schlauere leute als man selbst gemacht haben beid sei es ich werde es bloß noch mal checken if
meine mein count gleich gleich der upload sei es und wenn es wenn es nicht der fall ist
ja machen wir so ich gebe ich gebe das hier nur zurück irgendwie so und ansonsten gehen wir
zurück keine ahnung dass wir einen fehler sehen ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher was wir da
machen also also wenn ich wenn ich genau 20 mb eingelesen habe dann muss ich jetzt meine beid
sei es ausrechnen also sprich übrigens wie kann ich den rider einstellen dass der den mist hier
weg macht das sieht ja vollkommen beschissen aus muss einfach noch mal zumachen jetzt ist jetzt
ist besser besser zu lesen genau weil jetzt muss ich nämlich noch ausrechnen dass das ganze passt
als aber upload beid per second beid sei es wie das beid sei es vom und wir haben jetzt die
ganzen sachen ja hier in beid also von beid upload sei es durch und jetzt kommt die eigentliche
rechnung des upload speeds stopwatch elapsed ne nicht milliseconds milliseconds brauchen wir
nicht das ist wir wollen wir wollen beid pro sekunde haben also elapsed seconds wollen wir
haben milliseconds warte mal ich brauchte es als float seconds ist zu ungenau total seconds double
perfekt also der rechnet hier dann sowas aus wie 20 mb also 20 millionen 20 millionen durch zum
beispiel 35,5 7 8 9 5 2 3 7 5 5 5 1 9 3 5 sekunden und das sollte dann mein upload speed pro sekunde
sein das heißt das können wir jetzt noch umrechnen lassen in maybe beid oder in megabyte oder in was
auch immer upload beid per second als mega maybe ok leute ich muss mal kurz nachgucken mega versus
maybe ja als m bits könnten was auch machen da muss ich als bits da muss ich als bits umrechnen
ja aber wir zeigen es jetzt mal megabyte an das ist jetzt erstmal einfacher ok mega ne also
jetzt jetzt jetzt lassen wir uns erklären jetzt jetzt lassen wir uns das mal erklären also
maybe maybe ist 1024 das heißt mega ist 1000 alles klar also wollen wir es in maybe beid sammeln
stimmt sogar was ich da gemacht habe ok machen wir hier null oder minus eins machen wir hier minus
eins wir können wir können einfach einen fehler wir können einfach eine exception werfen und
nichts und nichts zurückgeben oder wir machen hier sowas wie error oder so alles klar so wunderbar
das müsste jetzt eigentlich passen wir können den kram hier hochladen ich hoffe das funktioniert
was ich hier konstruiert habe müssen wir gleich ausprobieren also wir können den kram hochladen
und ich stoppe die zeit und dann rechne ich das ganze aus ok wir testen es mal lokal wir
testen das mal kurz lokal ob das funktioniert was ich mir überlegt habe neu starten wir test
auch quatsch nicht auf dem server neu starten bringt ja nichts lokal neu starten
so wie mache ich das jetzt mit dem karl karl also karl x post kann ich mit karl irgendwie
einfach random daten hochladen geht das kann man kann man mit dem karl karl upload bites
habe binarie data posting karl ok habe ich noch nie gemacht hat irgendjemand von euch
ein plan wie das geht data binarie kann ich sagen ich kann nicht sagen data binarie von
def 0 20 mb oder so ne das geht wahrscheinlich nicht das ja aber dann dann will er dann dann
leder mehr hoch dann leder nicht 20 mb hoch ich mache mal hier noch eine console ausgabe
upload ich gebe das hier noch mal aus und auf sehr von ich könnte eine datei anlegen
ja aber würde das so funktionieren ich probiere ich probiere das mal aus also lokal host 5000
5000 speed jam ja wenn man das jetzt so richtig schreibt lokal host hey hey leute da kommt
da kommt schon mal ok interessant da gebe ich hier mal aus wie viel ab wie vieler wie
vieler hoch eingeladen hat hochgeladen hat count ok aber das ist schon mal interessant
zu wissen dass das überhaupt funktioniert 9 9 was 9 byte warum ausgerechnet sind das
9 characters kann das sein 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 8 er nimmt das literally nimmt er das also
muss ich das von von der datei oder das
das funktioniert ja ich muss eine datei anlegen also wie war das dds hat doch irgendjemand
den chat grad geschrieben genau das genau das genau das brauchen wir wobei mir nullen
reichen ehrlich gesagt vom def 0 out output dat 1 mb und das ganze 20 dann haben wir genau
20 20000 bytes hoffentlich versteht er unter m das gleiche wie asb.net dann aus ne ne macht
er nicht guck mal mal also wie geht das jetzt add output data einmal guck mal hier ok jetzt
muss ich eben genau jetzt muss ich ok ich will nicht 20 m ich will 20 maybe geht das hack
weight wisst ihr was wir machen es ganz anders easy 1 zu viel 1 2 3 4 5 so das braucht wahrscheinlich
jetzt zu lang mit 20000 wie mache ich wie mache ich denn jetzt genau 20 millionen kann
man mir machen das hatten wir doch schon das sind das ist das ist das das ist das old das
old school mb muss man machen mb alles klar ok perfekt mal gucken ob unser karl funktioniert
beim guck mal hier wir haben abgeloaded mit 1340 mb die sekunde näher das kann ja schon
sein ich meine ich lade ja über mein loopback interface hoch das ist ja quasi vom ram in
den ram wenn man so will was ich hier upload also ich lade mit mit schwankend hoch zwischen
ja 730 moment was was pro sekunde 730 mb pro sekunde ich meine das geht vom ram in den
ram das ist kein wunder dass das schnell ist ne das läuft nicht über den netzwerk schnittstelle
ich lasse es mal über den netzwerk schnittstelle laufen kann man nämlich ausprobieren ich lasse
es mal über den netzwerk schnittstelle laufen ja ach nee moment habe ich habe ich habe ich
habe ich hier einen karl habe ich hier einen karl unter windows ich habe einen karl poggers
keck weight nice aber ich habe kein dd wie kriege ich das jetzt über das wisst ihr
was heute ich deploy das jetzt einfach ins internet und gut ist easy geht status
20 mb limit push einfach nein ich mach das jetzt einfach auf den server drauf und probier
es da aus easy ups speedchamp backend pull jawoll und jetzt
das netrun ok probier was mal aus ip haben wir die hier vm vm is for my workstation ok
mein karl probier was mal aus speedchamp moment ok wait a minute wo habe ich meinen karl da
ah ich bin ja dumm moment ich bin ja dumm es ist nicht port 5000 es ist es ist https
und dann auch nicht das sondern ich bin ja richtig bescheuert meine güte speedchamp.org
es ist langsam der upload der upload ist fucking langsam es geht aber es ist fucking langsam
4mb die sekunde na gut 4mb die sekunde das kann doch sein ich habe 40mb upload das kann
doch sogar sein das ist gar nicht schlecht ich sag dem neul mal bescheid wegen stream
nebenbei ja funktioniert ja wieder erwarten funktioniert es tatsächlich erstaunlich
gut du kannst ja kannst ja mal bei mir grad in stream gucken jetzt warte hab ich ja ich
mach grad mit köln den upload test ne ich hab mir eine datei erstellt die 20mb groß
und ladet jetzt einfach mal hoch ok und du kriegst als antwort jetzt dass das 20mb mit
vier maybe maybe beid wohlgemerkt die sekunde hochgeladen wird das kommt ich hab 40mb upload
ich brauch 45mb zum stream das ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt ok ich bin ich bin überrascht
dass es tatsächlich so gut hinkommt ja also chat wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr es auch mal
ausprobieren mach ich auch magst du mir die datei mal schicken das sind 20mb große datei
mit nullen du kannst wenn du hast du nen nee das ist du bist unter windows ne ja ich kann
es eigentlich hab ich hab die git bash also wenn du mir den command schicken kannst mit
der ich die generieren kann achso dd hier moment dd da weiß halt nicht ob das unter
git bash funktioniert aber kann man mal ausprobieren moment kommt im discord da legt
es eine output output dat an die ist genau und die muss auch genau 20 milionen byte sein
weil das check da dass man nicht cheaten kann sonst ich schicke dir ich schicke dir auch
gleich mal das köln mit ja ok wunderbar könnt ihr mir ausprobieren chat wer bei euch schon
ausprobiert hat schickt mal den befehl in chat ok also ich post mal in chat was man
machen muss hier ist der köln befehl leute und hier ist das dd könnte ja mal ausprobieren
nehmen lieber random daten ja kann man auch machen das hast schon recht aber ob wir jetzt
nullen hochladen oder random daten macht doch erstmal keinen unterschied so achso ich wollte
dir auch noch schicken genau hier dd hier kannst du auch einfach nur in den chat ich
hab den ja offen ich hab es bei mir in chat gepost gerade da sind übrigens zwei kommandos
ich hab die ein bisschen doof hintereinander gepostet also das erste ist das dd das geht
und das zweite ist das köln mit dem dd links links links in die 20 mb daten mit dem köln
jetzt so hoch ja das ich sehe hier den speedtest von den leuten in meiner konsole kommt in
der ganze upload test der download test sollte dann natürlich deutlich schneller sein das
heißt spätestens dann wissen wir auch ob der kram funktioniert oder nicht komm mal
hier das erste erste erste exception am start wer war's wer war's wahrscheinlich ah expected
und als entweder hat er abgebrauchen hat zu viel hochgeladen also das limit ist standardmäßig
bei sp dot net core 30 mb was so was ein request groß sein darf sonst bricht er ab oder hat
es einer geschafft die ganze sache zu cheaten guck mal oder hat wirklich eine sehr sehr
sehr schnelle leitung stark aber der rest scheint ja halbwegs zu funktionieren oder
der rest scheint wirklich zu funktionieren so leute warum habt ihr alle so schnellen
upload jetzt wird mich ja auch der graf interessieren von hetzner
netzwerk netzwerk net working hier den hatten die früher unter netten netten bin ich jetzt
bin ich jetzt blöd wo haben die denn den netzwerk grafen ganz mal unter grafen gibt's
auch oben wieder blind wieder guck mal hier da ist den habe ich gesucht ok da geht doch
ein bisschen was die leute sind aber ausprobieren genau die laden direkt von hetzner ja hast
du du kannst an den du kannst dich jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht einloggen was man von hetzner klaut
so einfach zu hetzner klaut so aber probieren kann ach die leute machen es schon von hetzner
vm zu hetzner vm deswegen sind die so schnell weil ich wollte gerade sagen alter die leute
hier mit 300 mb in der sekunde was haben die für den upload der chat wieder das ist klar
das ist halt der vor und nachteil von technisch fähigen zuschauen vor und nachteil zugleich
das stimmt das stimmt du hast kläffere leute im chat aber du hast auch welche sind halt
die sind also besonders clever oh habt das abgelehnt hier wird schon wieder gespammt
ja aber bei mir bei mir ist halt ganz klar die 40 mbits zu erkennen wenn es ich gehe
noch mal rein ich probiere es jetzt noch mal aus ja also das funktioniert prinzipiell
wir müssen halt mal gucken wie zuverlässig das ist mit schnelleren verbindungen das können
wir dann mal ausprobieren spätestens wenn es vom hetzner server zum hetzner server
geht dann dann sollte es sollte es eigentlich funktionieren ich meine er hat ja eine recht
genaue auflösung der macht es ja auf also die stopp geht ja auf cpu tic basis also auch
wenn wenn ich total seconds nehme in wirklichkeit hat er ja noch irgendwie keine ahnung zwanzig
nachkommastellen genau ich kann oder so dabei oder was ist ein double was hatten das ich
habe keine ahnung aus dem kopf 14 stellen nicht sagen wer hat ahnung ja ok da aber
also ich bin ich bin schon mal ich bin schon mal zufrieden der upload test funktioniert
ja auf jeden fall ich bereite jetzt noch mal kurz vor dann pushe ich gleich noch mal was
dann kann man gucken ob es auch auch ob es auch so funktioniert perfekt was soll ich
irgendwie noch was spezielles einbauen oder hast du hast du bei deinem check testet er
genau ob der 20 ja er testet aber genau 20 mb mb hat also das können wir später ändern
es ist kein ich war gerade fragen sicher ja ok ja nee bei mir hat es ok guck mal guck
mal kurz in visual studio code vielleicht habe ich auch logikfehler drin kann ja sein
dass bei mir gerade viel aber guck mal in den controller ja du guckst du kannst das
nur und dann kann ablassen ja also ich habe es auch ich habe es auch vorhin probiert wenn
da was anderes hochlädt dann geht es selbst wenn es mehr ist wenn übrigens der wenn wenn
es nicht geht kriegst du minus eins zurück mir ist nichts besseres eingefallen also ich
würde sagen wir machen es später so wenn das nicht funktioniert der bricht dann einfach
ab und du kriegst gar nichts zurück der macht einfach der macht einfach die verbindung dann
mit einer fehler fehler fehler zu hat er keinen sinn ok ok alles klar warte dann push ich
das grad mal und dann kannst du das mal deployen weil dann sieht man was so geht push nice
jetzt muss mir noch ein github issue raussuchen den ich wieder fixe wie viele github issues
haben wir eigentlich mittlerweile schon offen hier auch du hast geschlossen hier ich habe
einen habe ich schon zugemacht ich will die zuschauer jetzt natürlich auch bloß noch
weitere hinzuzufügen speedchamp korn gibt's dann komm es gibt jetzt es gibt jetzt kryptowährung
die auf festplatten speicher geht kryptowährung die auf cpu leistung geht cp auf gpu leistung
geht noch kryptowährung die auf netzwerk wlan abdeckung geht dann kann man doch eigentlich
auch mal internet speedtest währung irgendwie machen es braucht einfach nur coinchamp coinchamp
das ist die ultimate das ist dann quasi die koin aller koin so ok ich habe gepusht ok
kryptowährung auf bandbreite gibt es schon warum wundert mich das nicht so also ich soll
pullen du sollst pullen ja ok auf dem server bei mir lokal ist ne warte stopp stopp ich
habe vergessen das frontend überhaupt zu bauen das wäre vielleicht noch smart einen
moment gehen wir noch kurz ja dann kann ich dann kann ich den leuten gleich zeigen genau
danach können wir das mit dem download ausprobieren und dann haben wir was was zumindest so der
spur einer funktion enthält die auch so aussieht auf den ersten blick als würde funktionieren
ja wir werden locker locker 40 minuten schneller gewesen wenn mein internet zeug hiermit gemacht
hätte es wäre ja auch langweilig wenn es einfach funktioniert ja bauder von hat sich
gemeldet also die können jederzeit umschalten der nächsten issue schließen das geht immer
laufen im band chat frag gerade wer du bist jemand mit dem ich auf youtube schon mal vor
einer woche oder so ein video hochgeladen habe wo wir uns über jobs it aktuelle it jobs
und arbeitgeber unterhalten haben und ja weiß ich so willst du noch irgendwas sagen wer
du bist ich bin ich bin ich bin informatikstudent auch youtuber da bisher mit youtube immer so
eine on off beziehung gehabt aber jetzt wieder aktiv und ja und heute wird agil programmiert
dann werde ich erstmal dann in der nächsten vorlesung von berichten direkt direkt den
lebenslauf die buchen mich dann direkt schon für workshops ok ich habe jetzt noch mal gepusht ok
gibt es remote update ich mache jetzt direkt auf dem server dass man reloaden kann ok dann
gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an speed jam.org pages not working 502 warum das liegt an mir das liegt
an mir gehe ich mal von aus ich bin dumm ich habe es nicht gestartet das ist manchmal da sieht man
mal wieder so sehr so sehr ich mich immer irgendwie agil und solche sachen lustig macht das hat
schon seine vorteile alles wenn man so einen automatischen workflow hat ne pushe und automatisch
deploy das ist halt wirklich so da muss man nicht die leute spammen wieder was das zeug kennt. Guck dir das mal
es wäre wirklich interessant zu wissen welche da wirklich tatsächlich über die website reinkommen
ja vielleicht wäre es jetzt sinnvoll zu sagen von welchem origin das kommt ja das wäre vielleicht
nicht verkehrt aber aber da ist es ok sollte ich mal klicken versuchst mal meine güte hier das ist
ja magic alda ja 4,7 das kommt ungefähr hin so ungefähr in dem dreh würde ich sagen gefühlt
hat es bei mir auch gedauert ja nice jetzt gucke ich gerade mein netzwerk was er sagt antwort ich
gucke mir einfach mal die response an dann sehe ich ja was was das back end meint was es ist ja
stimmt das habe ich ja noch nicht implementiert basically. Also musst du mal starten. Was fail to load response warum?
klick mal auf response drauf bis ihr auf preview ach ich bin ne aber der mag nicht warum nicht was
hat er für was hat er für schmerz der sollte zumindest minus eins oder so zurück zurück kriegen
ne bei mir schickt er tatsächlich auch keine antwort
schau mal im log ich würde ja gerne im log gucken aber das log wird von euch gerade so voll
gespammt da sehe ich nix du kannst ja mal nen console console log oder irgendwie so was machen
auf die auf die response ich glaube ich glaube es liegt am back end also also wenn wenn google
nichts anzeigt google chrome nichts anzeigt da wird wahrscheinlich nichts da sein ist aber komisch
weil sagen wir so das karl moment warum geht es jetzt nicht also wenn es mit karl geht warum geht
das mit chrome nicht ja also es passt ziemlich gut bei mir sind es ein bisschen upload weniger
das hängt wahrscheinlich einfach damit zusammen dass alle gerade auf diesen server ein passen
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ich würde es halt ich würde es halt echt gerne gucken was der antwort
so der vergleich halt ne der vergleich von dem was was du hier quasi on the fly ausrechnest und was
das back end misst es bringt jetzt aber auch nix wenn ich sage leute hört mal auf zu spammen
weil das machen sie nicht das das hat jetzt höchstens eine firewall einstellen schnell
und da muss man eine ip ne ne ne ne das da sieht man meine ip das das geht nicht aber wenn du das
bei hetzen da ist halt den tab nicht mehr öffnen ja super ja verstehe jetzt nicht also warum kriegt
er ich meine der der hat ja hat hat hat er einen fehler vielleicht wenn man das über die hast du
ja okay nie du machst er return u upload ich mache einfach mit karl mit karl geht's ja
mit karl krieg ich krieg ich krieg ich zurück ich guck mal kurz ins studio code rein uploader
muss man gucken warum naja dann kann es ja wahrscheinlich doch am frontend liegen
zeige mal wo ist denn dein wo ist denn das drinne wo muss ich gucken sauce ne sauce ja sauce js
ach hier exe aus post ah ok
ja calculate speed oh yes hier ist wirklich big brain time ich sehe es gerade wo es
on the fly berechnet wird so aber so genau habe ich verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht was
der für schmerzen hat mach einfach rate limit mich wundert warum der das im browser nicht
anzeigt ja das ist das ist irgendwie wird irgendwie klappt der request irgendwie wird
der request nicht fertig musste bei dir vielleicht hat bei mir mit dem chat geschrieben content
type noch setzen dass du sagst content type zurück application jason gute frage ne aber
der wird gesetzt ich wollte gerade sagen ich glaube das macht er ich habe das kapiert
also seit wir das das klappt und sehr merkwürdig kannst du mal eben im frontend ich habe jetzt
an der stelle nicht so wirklich den den durchblick aber du bist ja unten hast du irgendwie die die
results kannst du da irgendwie mal einen console lock oder sowas machen auf die ja ich mache
jetzt mal genau ich starr das mal bei mir schickst du auch genau 20 mb ja aber selbst wenn du
müsste zumindest minus eins zurückkommen also es müsste auf jeden fall was zurückkommen
ja du kannst ja mal ein lock machen also ich bekomme ich bekomme meinen rate zurück den ich dir schicke jetzt
ist die frage wahrscheinlich vielleicht schicke ich dir das falsch das kann sein also ich schicke
dir definitiv keine recht richtig richtig ich schicke dir als request body einfach den buffer
von diesem intervall aber wo ist hier und ab wo schickst du es hier genau buffer from data hier
genau ist vielleicht vielleicht weil jetzt krieg ich nicht deine ich krieg nicht deine jason response
krieg ich nicht zurück tromm rafft nicht firefox schon ach im firefox gehts magst du das mal ich
habe firefox ich probiere ich probiere das gerade mal aus das wäre jetzt aber merkwürdig
und da sieht man auch gleich mit dark theme ich mache mal den dark wieder aus so ok network
bei mir gehts kaum und firefox gleich gut das hat die frage jaja kannst du jetzt einmal gucken ob
er da auch eine ich bin ich bin gerade am gucken hier request der firefox hängt bei mir mega was
denn da los request ach nee der request ist einfach nur diesen groß ne ich krieg auch das
rate zurück lull aber 4096 nur nur 4006 90 bytes nein nein das sind nee das ist schon aber
darstellung anders ok keine ahnung aber in der response steht es drin ich bin ja auch dumm ich
habe im request geguckt und response passt also in ja du hast in mit ich habs in mein
meiner response ist mehr wie bald aber ich kann das umrechnen ich kann es auch in ambit machen ok
ja ambit werde ich mal aber das kommt das kommt glaube ich ungefähr hin guck mal mit
2 mb weit mal gucken ob google das kann das kommt ungefähr hin also google meint 32,358
moment hier megabit sind 3,8 mb weit und das backend ist der meinung es sind 4,1 mb weit
das kommt recht gut hin würde ich sagen also 0,3 mbit da schwankungen dazwischen kann ich
mir schon vorstellen wo ist das vertritt wo ist das verpflichtende impressum wollen es wieder
wissen wir verfolgen keinerlei gewinn absichten damit das privat telemedien gesetzt geht nicht
jetzt jetzt geht es bei mir lokal ich habe bei mir die ich habe die request header geändert ich
habe es den content type auf so ein octet stream gesetzt irgendwo auf google stand dass das
vielleicht so geht so da kannst du noch mal pushen und ich ich push das jetzt auch einfach mal mit
dem console log response genau da können wir kommen ja das liegt anscheinend echt an irgendwie
das firefox standardmäßig davon ausgeht wenn da viel weit geschwurbel reinkommt und chrome sagt
wenn der heiter nicht gesetzt ist dann juckt mich das net ich mache hier auf dem server mal
wird immer noch gespammt als fang er kann er nicht mal beenden weil das so viel noch im
buffer drin hat ok remote update und pull run mir fällt übrigens eigentlich sollte es vielleicht
nicht im debug run auf dem server sondern release mode anmachen also ein bisschen schneller also
reloads sagt reload gucken wir mal gucken wir uns das mal an ich probiere es mal im raum aber
sehr schön dynamisch wie das und fleißig in welchem zeitintervall guckst du so oder machst
du einfach über den kompletten zeitintervall drüber und das ist ich kriege immer event und
immer wenn das event vom browser aus geschossen wird update ich das guckst du quasi an zwischen
letztem oder zählst du einfach insgesamt auch hoch durch zeit oder insgesamt durch zeit ja
bei mir gibt es im chrome immer noch nicht aber ich gucke mal in die konz in die konsole ein cash
vielleicht noch kurz das ja manchmal ich mache mal cash das ist abel cash so ist abel cash kann
auch sein dass das ist viel aber nichts doch nicht korrekt gepusht haben oder so du hast
irgendein sonderzeichen im tailwind css drin guck mal das ist irgendwie ja tailwind css add
ozent 5e stark verstehe ich nicht aber es funktioniert trotzdem
ja das so ein häuschen und ich kriege irgendwie auch nix in der konsole das guck mal stehe ich
nicht ja der chat aber ausprobiert hier es hat eine ausprobiert speedtest 10 10 m bit und
speedchamp 9,56 m bit also scheint doch ungefähr zu stimmen was wir da machen ja also bei mir bei
mir lokal wenn ich starte bekomme ich jetzt ein response zurück jetzt wundert mich halt nur
warum es da noch nicht gebaut ist so ich probiere es mal bei mir lokal gerade mal aus weiß auch
nicht warum das bei sonst kannst mal gucken ob die code änderung war ich kurz im github kann sein
dass ich auch so sehen also ich habe ich habe in der konsole in der konsole kommt nix
hast du es auch neu gepullt ja ich habe ich habe remote abdeck ich guck mal was was du
geändert hast im letzten commit genau schau mal also ich habe ich habe remote abdeck gemacht
gepullt also passt alles geht lock minus 1 minus p ja du hast text octet stream hinzugeschrieben
hinzugeschrieben und konsole lock response was auch immer ok warte ich baue es jetzt noch mal
und push es noch mal kann sein dass er einfach nicht korrekt übernommen hat stimmt stimmt stimmt
stimmt es war es wurde kein ww root wurde nicht geupdatet richtig genau ja der chat sagt es
passieren komische dinge wenn man schnell den upload button spamt aber wahrscheinlich die aktivierst du es nicht dass
es ein zweites mal uploadet wenn man klickt oder ja genau genau das kann man noch machen
aber aber aber die reports im chat passen gut speed test neun fünf neun fünfzig mbit speed
gem 57 mbit also wunderbar also leute es kann sein dass es bei manchen von euch riesige
unterschiede gibt dann liegt es wahrscheinlich daran dass die verbindung zu dem einen oder zu
dem anderen eben unterschiedlich gut ist ich habe nicht auf release gebaut aber das solltet
jetzt nicht den riesen unterschied machen kann er aber gleich machen sag wenn ich wenn ich gucken
kann erst ich push es gerade ich habe ein update er war euch ein error ist noch nix da ja es geht
nicht so schlecht oder ich habe die falschen oder gelöscht wir haben zum klug alles eingecheckt
in das netrun minus c release oder so ob dann dann lässt das in optimis laufen
sie diskutieren kratzer im chat drüber wie man den service am besten zu spamt
das nächste mal machen wir folgendermaßen wobei weißt du was wir machen könnten ich
könnte basic aus davor machen mit meinem proxy die und nur wir haben das password wir sperren
euch aus chat aber noch hält der server ja aus es ist geil ich versuche das zu beenden
und es braucht zehn sekunden bis alles weg ist genau so ist das test bei mir sagte everything
up to date also ich habe es gebaut und an sich kommt es auch im richtigen verzeichnis raus
ich habe was vergessen von 16 59 ich nenne den kommet dumm jetzt ok jetzt gucke ich mal ins
letzte log ja minifight ist javascript sieht immer so toll aus ja es wunderbar ok also
dann dort netrun release und gucken wir noch mal startet da ist es und jetzt kriege ich
auch was in der konsole data upload ja jetzt funktioniert ist gar nicht übel hier sagt
der upload 30,68 bei mir sind bei mir sind das 3,7 maybe maybe bald muss noch mal kurz
umrechnen lassen im bittum sind 3,6 hey das ist ziemlich gut du hast gemessen 3,65 und
das becken ist dann 3,79 also da kannst du dich nicht beschweren das ist ziemlich nahe
beieinander das stark das stark dann kannst du ja noch das dann in dem in dem response
als mbit ja geben und dann setzt sich quasi einfach wenn die response da ist überschreibe
ich die werte einfach wieder genau genau gut das ist ja das ist ja aktuell nur nur upload
test wir müssen uns überlegen wie wir das machen mit dem mit dem response wollen wir
einfach zwei zwei sachen die du aufrufst machen ein upload test und ein download test oder
ja das heißt im endeffekt genau wenn der upload fertig ist oder man fängt mit dem
download an download ich mir einfach einen array buffer von dir ja warum lasst ihr überhaupt
den client das ist eine gute frage warum lasst ihr überhaupt den client messen server sollte
doch ausreichen naja dass man mal was sieht während man den knopf drückt was das ist
der einzige grund zählen wird das was auch im server gemessen wird aber es ist natürlich
schon cool das muss ja zugeben leute wenn man hier auf den knopf drückt und es passiert
direkt was ne exactly so ein bisschen user experience genau sehr schön
wunderbar dann also wir können es auf zwei zwei arten könnten was können was machen
entweder wir machen ich gehe mal kurz ich bin mal kurz im code studio code also wir
könnten noch einen zweiten zweiten hier test machen für mit quasi dann keine ahnung da
muss ich das ding aber um benennen weil ich habe spät spät schämt da müssen wir
slash spät schämpf ab und slash spät schämpf down machen oder du hast einfach slash
ab slash down oder so oder oder wir machen einfach so wir lassen den spät schämpf
weg und machen nur ab und down genau genau so oder wir könnten das alles hier in einem machen
weil ich kann dir also dann können wir aber halt kein response hier hier drinnen machen
also ich könnte die jetzt quasi wenn man spät wenn du slash spät schämpf aufrufst
als erstes kannst du was hochladen und als zweites würde ich dir dann einfach 20 mb
wieder zurückschicken dann müsstest du aber halt anderweitig den die results abfragen
er ist halt dann dann die frage war im endeffekt muss der server ja trotzdem noch irgendwie
berechnen wie es ist weil sonst wäre es ja wieder der client der dafür zuständig wäre
sind sie theoretisch theoretisch was wir was du machen könntest ist du du zählst einfach
ab wie lange der upload dauert und die uploadzeit können wir dann von dem von der gesamte zeit des
requests abziehen ich kann das wobei ich kann den download ja auch stoppen also mal angenommen ich
würde dir jetzt direkt nachdem der upload durch ist direkt nachdem der upload durch ist schicke
ich dir einfach 20 mb zurück und das kann ich ja auch stoppen wie lange es dauert bis es bei dir
ankommt das können wir einfach mal ausprobieren das einzige dumme ist nur dann kann ich dir in
diesem request keine results zurückschicken weil naja weil du kriegst ja schon per download was
also das funktioniert da nicht da müssen wir genau dass das meinte ich halt weil die dadurch keine
results bekommen genau die dann machen wir dann machen wir ab und da und zum testen ja ja ja und
also wir können ja dann wie gesagt wir haben brauchen heute eh wenn er nicht komplett fertig
bin ich mir ziemlich sicher wenn ich mir das mensch auf die uhr guck 18 uhr das können wir
dann irgendwann das nächste mal überlegen ob wir es nicht so machen dass wenn man die dass man die
ergebnisse speichern kann also sprich dass du dir irgendwie so einen token abrufst am anfang dass
du quasi so eine id pro messung kriegst und der server dann passend zu dieser id sich die werte
irgendwie speichert genau ich glaube das können wir so machen dann gucken da machen wir das so
also machen wir slash down und slash ab nur dass ich halt den kram dir schicke du kannst ja mal
gucken dass du das dem axios irgendwie beibringen kannst dass das dann auch noch dann auch noch
abruft jetzt ich guck da mal gut dann sagst du einfach wenn es fertig ist ich sag dir bescheid
frage wie lange willst du heute machen wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so lange ich auch nicht also ich würde
jetzt wir machen die download funktionieren würde ich auch sagen ich habe dann übels hunger jetzt
schon das machen wir machen den download fertig da sieht man nämlich dass es prinzipiell funktioniert
und über die über die genaue architektur und wie man dann vielleicht einzelne sachen speichern
und so können wir uns nächstes mal überlegen genau genau das machen wir heute ich hoffe euch
gefällt es bis jetzt leider ein bisschen technische probleme technische probleme
zwischendurch aber wir geben alles ja ich hoffe auch bei dir drüben im stream ich habe den chat
gar nicht mehr auf aber ich hoffe euch gefällt alles alles glaube ich richtig richtig poggers
sagt der chat das freut mich huge pock alles klar ich sag dir bescheid kann er schon mal
dein chat kann sich ja schon überlegen welches emote wie er noch mal welche sich doch da
reinklatschen soll genau das war das noch nicer ist könnt ihr euch ja mal überlegen was wir
machen wollen irgendwie keks emotes was auch immer ein meme bildchen könnt euch könnt
euch überlegen was wir wollen ich mein ich habe aber ich habe vielleicht noch mit einem link zu
einem high end auflösenden bild oder so das wäre super das wäre natürlich noch besser ja das
kann man gucken das ist nicht so aktuell hast du einfach nur knop und 3 3 zeilen mit ja zahlen
drin ist ja das mal da lockst du kein irgendwie mehr hinter irgendwo hervor mit mit der optik
perfekt also machen was lächelt dauernd da werde ich das jetzt mal kurz basteln alles
klar ich sage dir gleich bescheid denke mal so zehn minuten oder so ok alles klar bis gleich
discord hat mein hotkey gelöscht jetzt ok geht wieder ich mache jetzt aus ok leute
dann werden wir das mal programmieren wir sind ja super agil wir können so was on the fly ändern
aber ich kann das relativ einfach in mbit umrechnen ich sag nämlich hier einfach upload
bytes per second in bits und jetzt habe ich bits pro sekunde und jetzt muss ich das ganze
einfach nur mal 1000 mal 1000 rechnen habe ich mbit oder stimmt das stimmt das hat es
gemp müsste eigentlich so stimmen dann war mal jetzt hier war upload mbits so dann haben
ich auch die mbits ob's bits 1000 mal 1000 ok alles ich mein könnt ihr natürlich dann
auch eine million schreiben aber so finde ich es lesbar ok upload mbits per second upload
mbits per second minus eins da müssen wir uns so für die fehler wir geben keine antwort
wir sagen hier throw new new exception hack wait so perfekt beste exception ok dann machen
wir das ganze jetzt mal verdauert also sprich das ist der upload test und das hier wird
der download test down dann nenne ich das einfach mal so down und das ist ab ja jetzt ich konnte
leider den chat grad nicht so lesen jetzt sagt mal ich wollte soll mir öfter so was
machen ich meine jetzt nicht jeden tag ist klar ist auch viel zu anstrengend und wird
dann wahrscheinlich auch langweilig mit der zeit aber so ab und zu mal so einmal in alle
zwei wochen oder einmal in der woche oder irgendwie sowas toll nice ist mega cool chat
soll ich euch mal ehrlich ehrlich sagen das freut mich ihr wisst ich bin ich kann das
immer schlecht so expressen ja aber das freut mich ehrlich wirklich dass euch das gefällt
white people happy ist nicht agil genug was müsste man renee was müsste man machen für
mehr agilness daily stand up ja ist super heute nice wir können ja auch mal die nächsten
streams über so eine kleine projektliste machen immer wenn uns was einfällt was man
hier so machen könnte weil wichtig ist dass wir das darf nicht zu groß sein ihr seht doch
wir haben ein easy as fuck projekt hier eigentlich und wir machen da ewig dran rum ok also wir
brauchen jetzt erstmal den controller für download und wir brauchen übrigens noch den
controller für ping fällt mir gerade ein ping einfach zweimal aufrufen oder so keine
andere fällt mir noch nichts so nichts großartiges zu ein community projekt ja da muss ich mal
gucken also download wie kann man die download wie kann man den download messen ich würde
sagen wir machen das exakt genauso wie bei dem anderen wir nehmen ich einfach eine download
size download size 20 megabytes download size und jetzt verschicken wir das einfach ich
glaube das ist sogar noch einfacher weil ich glaube das ist noch noch also das ist jetzt
glaube ich richtig easy as fuck das download ding zu zu basteln wir brauchen einen buffer
der so groß ist wie die upload size und nicht wie die download size und jetzt und jetzt
können wir einfach sagen hier a weight response body right und jetzt schreiben wir einfach
den kompletten buffer rein fertig mehr müssen wir nicht machen dann brauchen wir noch stopwatch
gucken wie lange das dauert bis er das ganze versendet hat stopp und dann machen wir genau
das gleiche wie hier manchmal schön copy pasten also im moment count den account kann es
wach sind was mache ich hier das ist blödsinnig das ist blödsinnig aber kann man so cheaten
kann man so cheaten beim download wirklich mal gucken also upload size download download
ich hoffe ich verschreibe mich in irgendwo das sind m bits download size geteilt durch
zeit vergangen was programmiert ihr einen speed test einen speed test du kannst dir
den übrigens schon angucken gerade geh mal auf speedchamp.org so die allererste basic
variante funktioniert sogar schon guck kannst hier drauf klicken und dann zeigt er dir an
dass du upload hast wird übrigens schon voll gespammt hier also hier uploads m bits per
second und das ist dann download m bits per second fast so vielleicht machen wir hier
eine ordentliche beschreibung download speed m bits per second und dann machen wir hier
daraus upload speed dass man aber ordentliche ordentliche anzeige hat upload speed ok wunderbar
sollte nun eigentlich funktionieren testen wir mal lokal testen wir mal lokal ob das ob
das klappt 20 mb alles klar probieren wir mal aus erstmal den hier pullen und run so
und jetzt haben wir curl ach so moment ich brauch gar keinen post das könnte man sogar
als das könnte man eigentlich sogar als als get machen wozu den post für den download
ne egal kann man so lassen die seite ist scheiß das funktioniert noch gar nichts ja würde
ich sagen wie heißt so schön geduld ich kann mir so sprüche nicht merken also probieren
wir das ganze jetzt mal hier lokal aus lokal host lokal host post und jetzt down ob geht
das jetzt einfach so moment ich muss jetzt was upload ich muss jetzt was upload um was
zu downloaden moment das ergibt keinen sinn warum muss ich was uploaden um was down zu
loan wait down ach so ich machs ja auch falsch ich brauche auch lokal host lokal host 5.000
das hat er für schmerzen warum kackt ab was was möchte mir dort net damit jetzt sagen
vielleicht soll ich dann get raus machen dass ich machte man get raus aber er hat schon
da noch what the fuck moment moment ich muss mal kurz gucken ob der upload noch funktioniert
ob ich jetzt aber ich jetzt irgendwie kaputt gemacht habe ab ich mache mal bei jetzt ich
muss durch bei jetzt machen nicht durch und nicht mal etwas stimmte doch nicht bisschen
verkehr drum ja das sieht besser aus wenn es ist lokal aus das geht vom ram ins ram
aber das ist schon das ist schon das sieht schon realistischer aus warum benutzt du dafür
nicht beid sei es weil es das lustigerweise nicht kann guck mal upload per second bits
kannst du wirklich bits es kann das es heißt ja auch beid sei es und ich bitt sei es hat
man bitt sei es gibt es nicht das ist aber ehrlich gesagt bisschen dumm dass man das
moment moment was ist beid in tb beid bitts in bitt simple das kann er kann er nicht aber
das das sieht jetzt realistischer aus so wir machen da jetzt ein get raus hatte tp get
mehr brauchen wir das eigentlich warum kackt es ab download speed warum kackt es ab response
has already started was genau möchtet ihr uns mitteilen wo ist wo wo wo wo ist das problem
mache ich jetzt irgendwie was body right es so ein buffer klingt klingt eigentlich erst
einmal sinnvoll was ich da mache ich hab keine ahnung warum der abkackt ehrlich gesagt null
er versucht zweimal den gleichen response zu schreiben du kannst unten nicht return
ach stimmt ja natürlich geht das nicht natürlich geht das nicht ja klar ich kann hier unten
keine response machen weil die response da oben ist ja schon das muss ich dem nur einmal
erzählen dass die logik nicht funktioniert das funktioniert nicht so wie wir uns das
gedacht haben weil du kannst du kannst ja mal kurz kurz bei mir gucken im stream ich habe
nicht so viel die latrine also folgendermaßen ich habe es jetzt auf die gleiche art versucht
wie im upload ja kannst du sagen wenn du es wenn du editor siehst ich sehe ihn ja ja
hast ja response body right async und dann schreibe ich dir 20 mb raus ich kann dir aber
nicht im gleichen request 20 mb bytes rausschreiben und noch eine json response geben weil es
gibt ja nur eine response für deinen request also ich kann ja nicht 20 bytes reinschreiben
und noch den json response im gleichen request also das das funktioniert nicht also wir müssen
es wahrscheinlich so machen dass wir das quasi das starten und du in dem zweiten in dem zweiten
request dann deine results abrufst im endeffekt klar du kannst es ich sehe es bei den chat
theoretisch die embells in den response header packen das könnte funktionieren ich weiß
nicht ob ich die header darf ich dir das probiere ich jetzt mal aus ob ich die header anpassen
darf wenn ich den response schon gestartet habe ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das auch
dass das nicht ich also ich weiß nicht wie das bei c sharp ist ich meine bei javas spring
boot kann es im endeffekt einfachen response objekt zurückgegeben und da die headers anpassen
ich weiß nicht wie das das geht das kann ich ja auch mal aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob ich in die response was reinschreiben darf nachdem ich vorher schon 20 mb bytes reingeschrieben
habe ich weiß halt nicht wie ich glaube ich glaube nicht dass das dass das funktioniert
bei x header x header denken wir denken uns was eigenes aus ich glaube aber nicht dass
es funktioniert x header kann speed champ so value moment wie macht man das überhaupt
string value testweise machen wir da 2000 rein da das funktioniert nicht probierst mal aus
top da müssen wir uns was anderes ausdenken nope ah ne moment ich geb hier unten den kram
noch zurück machen wir das weg und also es ist halt wie gesagt die frage wie das da genau
gehandelt wird erst header dann body andersrum gehts nicht dachte der chat ja gut aber erst
header geht ja nicht weil erst header da kann ich kann ja nicht was setzen wo ich noch nicht
weiß was rauskommt ne funktioniert nicht also der ich darf da nicht reinschreiben sobald
schon begonnen habe ich weiß halt nicht wie das bei c sharp geregelt ist weil du ja ich
glaube das also von der idee her kann das ja gar nicht funktionieren dass was der hier
macht ist mit body right das ist ja unter umgehung jeglicher framework logik schreibt
er in den in den in den htp request stream einfach seine 22 20 m bit rein das heißt
sein browser sieht sind 20 m bits und dann würden irgendwelche htp header folgen was
ja überhaupt keinen sinn ergibt an sich an sich ja an sich ja im endeffekt dann müsste
man als einfach so machen dass du nur den body zurückschickst und ich die zeit stoppe
ja dann das heißt also das wäre jetzt so die erste lösung die man angehen genau ich schicke
nur den body zurück und da kannst du ja die zeit schon mal reinschreiben das ist dann
natürlich nicht schiedsicher aber dann machen das das nächste mal so wir machen dann wirklich
so eine art mess session auf und du rufst dir dann einfach die ergebnisse mit einem
dritten request am ende ab oder drin steht das können wir dann als nächstes machen
dann haben wir das jetzt so ich gebe ich gebe nur den ich lese einfach nur ich schreibe
einfach nur raus sonst nix das müsste jetzt aber auch funktionieren ja das funktioniert
ok wenn ich das jetzt mal pushen dann kann man das ausprobieren dann habe ich hunger
implement ich kann nicht mehr schreiben mal das heißt im endeffekt was ich jetzt mache
bei post ich meine ich mache es nicht zeitgleich du hast jetzt einmal slash up und einmal slash
down ich habe slash up und slash down ja slash up hat sich nix geändert dran ist genauso
wie vorher und jetzt gibt es halt noch slash down da kriegst du aber nix zurück das sind
get requests genau ja da wir kommen da bestimmt auch eine bessere bessere idee der chat sagt
auch schon macht über web sockets macht über web rtc nebenbei jaja über machen wir uns
über alles gedanken wenn über web sockets ist keine schlechte idee könnte man könnte
man schon auch machen dann ist das so ein bisschen unabhängig davon aber das kann
man ausprobieren haben wir haben wir das stimmt das ist ein cooles projekt mehr das ist an
sich übersichtlich genug dass man da jetzt nicht komplett ja so den durchblick verliert
da kann man auch mal zwei drei wochen nix machen und ja blickt immer noch durch und
es ist insofern auch überschaubar dass man im stream mitkommt das eigentlich optimales
streamprojekt hier das stimmt an sich schon das ist ja im endeffekt egal die duration
kurz gucken was forder vorhin geschrieben hat weil ich habe ihnen gesagt sie sollen
jetzt bloß nicht mein modem noch mal neu starten oder sowas sind die ab und down fahre
schon online moin noch mal ich jetzt kann ich das gleich mal testen der spam hat übrigens
nachgelassen das hätte ich nicht sagen soll ich hätte einfach zur kenntnis nehmen sollen
gut wäre okay ich habe es wieder gestartet müsste jetzt da sein alles mein download
werde da noch nicht probieren mal kurz von mir aus aus ob das mit down slash down ist
es nicht nicht nicht ja ja also der request der request geht durch okay aber aber aber
ich kriege noch keinen ja genau request funktionieren schau mal hier stack overflow
ja gut klar das kann man machen wenn ich nicht die eingebaute controller logik benutze
sondern was eigenes basteln dann klar kann mich ja keiner daran hindern da reinzuschreiben
was ich will aber ich will es jetzt das nicht total verbiegen würde für das das kriegen
wir hin ich glaube uns fällt da schon noch was gutes ein ja ich hoffe mein mbit umrechnen
funktioniert ich probiere gerade noch mal aus upload upload
34 passt die cool aus chat mein die upload rechnung ist kaputt bei mir ist alles gut
34 mbit das ist ziemlich dementsprechend was ich auch habe schau mal im browser ach ist
der upload im browser kaputt okay das kann sein guck mal ach so der ist tatsächlich kaputt
na gut im browser ist klar dass es nicht funktioniert kann er nicht funktionieren kann er nicht
funktionieren falsche uhr also die freundin von java script aber auf der anderen seite
hey ich bin ich bin ich bin immer noch da also ich habe ja früher javascript geflamed
immer ja aber mittlerweile ist das schon ganz nett man kann aber wirklich gut was mit machen
das stimmt erstmal github issue aufmachen die leute lasst mal github issues in ruhe wir
haben schon genug auch wir haben welche geschlossen perfekt macht spaß einmal profis zuzuschauen
nicht sicher ob ob ich habe ich habe meine 20 ich habe meine 20 mb test datei geerdet
oder hast du die aus versehen geerdet aber ich weiß nicht ob das warst du das 20 mb
das datei geerdet naja gibts schlimmeres da haben wir halt 20 mb nullen im repo drin
das darf ja aber keinem guten repo fehlen sag ich immer so ich push das jetzt mal ich
weiß aber nicht ob das so korrekt ist weil bei mir werden sehr unterirdische werte angezeigt
probier mal aus sag sag wenn ich testen soll ich push das jetzt mach ich mach schon mal
den alten krempel aus wann implementiert ihr blockchain alter der witz hat so einen bad
mittlerweile du bist da 50 oder so der den gebracht hat ich will ein jira board dann
mach legt auf dir dein jira board sorg dafür dass wir hier so es gibt es gibt auch bestimmt
irgendwelche agilitätswettbewerbe oder so dann melden wir uns einfach für andermit
mit dem projekt ja man ja certified agile professionell oder sowas oh nein ich glaube
ich mache jetzt aus versehen merch oder so der fragt dich jetzt du hast gepullt und
schon committed so vorher bei dir ne ne ich hab nicht gepullt ich hab es auch schon gepusht
aber es passt du kannst falls du es nicht kennst du kannst wenn du wenn du pulst dann
sagt er ja wenn du wenn sich lokal was geändert hat und remote geändert hat dann fragt er
dich ob du es rein merken willst lokal du kannst sagen gett pull minus minus rebase
dann macht er die änderung von remote und dann deins obendrauf ohne merch okay okay
das kenne ich das nicht so hatte ich gerade nicht im kopf wunderbar ich mache den ganzen
tag irgendwie irgendwelche gett geschichten es ist aber noch nicht da meins ist das letzte
implement download so genau also ich habe jetzt deins ist quasi wieder on top aber meine
änderung sollten als auch mit drin sein mit dem ww root okay ist das in dumm drin oder
was ne das also ich habe kommet ich habe kommet von dir ich habe kommet von dir dumm und implement
download von mir dann letzt moment moment warum ich habe wieder die hälfte vergessen alles klar
ich habe nur update gemacht und nicht gepullt alles klar hier ist es okay sehr schön dann
genau das mal release und gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert gibt schon ein fork ja tut euch kein
zwang an leute folgt folgt was das zeug hält okay es läuft wieder ich mache an und jetzt
machen wir erst mal speedchamp starten doch die download also was ich noch implement was ich
noch implementieren muss ist dass ich das reside berücksichtige das ist jetzt noch nicht drin aber
selbst jetzt ist es halt sehr weit entfernt stimmt nicht beim download so also beim upload stimmt
bei mir auch gerade nicht der download nah das also der upload ist vorher gut vorher hat er
ziemlich gut hingehauen jetzt ist es die hälfte von dem von dem eigentlichen upload und download
ist halt auch komplett komplett verkehrt kann das sein kann das sein dass der zu viel lockt
oder so viel ist das gar nicht 20 m 20 m bit zum download ist zu gering ja aber der upload
stimmt auch nicht hast du irgendwas am upload jetzt gemacht an dem code hinter dem upload
ne oder gar nicht gar nicht äh warum warum haben wir ah der macht gleichzeitig upload und download
jetzt nein halt stopp eigentlich habe ich da ein await reingehauen ne macht er auch nicht macht
er auch nicht macht er auch nicht eben macht er nicht dann weiß ich nicht aber je öfter ich
das mache das besser deswegen wird wahrscheinlich schon beim download auf jeden fall an der geringen
datei größe liegen wahrscheinlich ja das kann sein das kann sein ich kann es ja noch
mal bei mir lokal testen aber warte mal was sagt er denn bei mir wenn ich wenn ich das hier in
der kommando zeile mache ich sehe es jetzt natürlich wieder nicht weil gespammt wird es fack
das müssen wir dann mal in ruhe erforschen so nächsten strich absolut absolut macht jetzt
hier upload ganz schön lang ich glaube ich glaube mal ich glaube das ist bei mir
kann wirklich einfach langsamer es gibt keine output dat in dem ordner wo ich bin
jetzt geht bei mir ist noch da ja ok ich dachte das mal eben mal doch aber warum dauert das jetzt
so lang wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich sind alle wie verrückt am spam aber maybe maybe aber was
man sagen kann es funktioniert halbwegs die selber ist selber ist nicht da und aber so was
gekrascht ich glaube das war zu viele leute also nicht anwenden anwendung ist gekrascht
schau mal in die hetsner grafen ja moment moment ich guck mal krieg gleich krieg gleich einen
gleichen anruf aus naja naja nee geht eigentlich geht eigentlich guck mal wir haben hier in out
ungefähr gleich viel 60 60 mb die sekunden 60 mb die sekunde das ist jetzt ja also geht
ja eigentlich so ich habe neu gestartet mal gucken dass irgendwas bringt upload 31 ok jetzt
blick ich nicht mal durch das jetzt jetzt noch 31 kommt auch in 31 mit jetzt testen wir im frontend
es stimmt nicht und vorne nicht es stimmt hinten noch ich komme jetzt auf 30 m bits ich auch im
download ok ich würde sagen das müssen wir uns dann am nächsten auch mal anschauen dass
ich dachte ans nächsten stream machen wir so ich mache da einen basic aus davor dass nur wir beide
mit dem mit log in drauf kommen weil das sind das sind gut geht er geht er so nicht stopp ich
nehme ich den server jetzt da hat sich ausgespammt vielleicht passt das threading im back end nicht
nur das macht das kann das kann asp.net eigentlich ganz dort net core eigentlich ganz gut muss da
nichts machen gut ich mach mal mach mal den server aus hat sich jetzt genug gespammt und ich kann
mich auch ich kann mich auch nicht mehr richtig konzentrieren aber wir haben trotzdem ich habe
noch mal gefragt wo ich mich gemütet habe heute es fanden alle gut nochmal frage so kann man bei
den bei den anderen bei dir auf dem channel an die leute wie hat es euch gefallen ich hoffe
euch ich hoffe euch jetzt auch total ehrlich bleiben werden eigentlich weitere folgen von
IT Security kommen bei mir werden auf jeden fall noch weitere folgen von IT Security kommen
muss mir noch erst mal auseinandersetzen was als nächstes kommt wissen wir schon wann es weitergeht
das doch nicht so nicht so wirklich nee wenn es halt passt wahrscheinlich unter unter der
woche eher nicht weil das geht bei uns ja beiden dann nur nachmittags und wenn du den tag schon
über irgendwelche sachen in der richtung gemacht hast dass da abends jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
noch dreieinhalb stunden programmierkram zu machen vor allem da muss man sich auch hier
wirklich ein bisschen konzentrieren und machen und tun deswegen würde ich eher sagen was was
irgendwas in richtung wochenende oder feiertag oder urlaub oder so genau ja wir ja gucken hat
mir auf jeden fall wirklich viel spaß gemacht war eine richtig coole geschichte und leute
mal guck mal beim neu vorbei ich poste noch mal kurz dein youtube link jetzt könnt ihr alle
mal vorbei gucken wer es nämlich noch nicht gesehen hat wir haben da anfang des jahres auch
mal ein video zusammen gemacht wo es um die physio ausbildung ging und zwar im januar oder
so vor drei monaten ja schon im märz märz ist schon ein bisschen hin aber könnt ihr euch mal
angucken wenn ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt und wir sagen mal schluss oder man ist dass so viele
dabei waren auf jeden fall auf jeden fall und gerade mal schnell ob ich den hausen kann
aber sehr nice also super geschichte und wir machen auf jeden fall weiter jetzt so wir wissen
bloß nicht genau wann wann genau okay dann würde ich sagen ich mach stream aus bis zum
nächsten mal macht's gut ja auch ja drei und ich muss noch in den hohen den lost rain point rate
klar bin gleich gleich aus
was rate dachten alles klar